Red Skull uses the Tesseract to open a
portal decades before Shield's Project
Pegasus would use it the same way this
tentacled creature with a mouth full of
sharp teeth is never named but I'm
thinking it could be one of the Elder
gods or many angled ones from the
2009-2010 realm of King's Marvel Comics
The Many angled ones are lovecraftian
interdimensional beings that look a lot
like this this Multiverse stuff is
getting harder and harder to understand
but so far in the Marvel Multiverse it
seems like you have timelines and
universes which are realities parallel
to our own that sometimes Branch off
from each other to form new ones as we
saw in Loki but then in between those
timelines you have what Marvel seems to
be calling dimensions in Realms that
they say are beyond space and time and
these are the surreal acid trips that we
see like in the doctor strange movies
the dark dimension also the quantum
realm and I think in a dimension like
this is where the many angled ones
reside that could explain how Peggy
Carter ended up going through that
Dimension to end up in the present day
much like Scott Lang's Quantum realm
time dilation and Avengers end game
[Music]